ah here we go again welcome to this
video so mr. woody gasps knowing him he
will probably play the same utterly
boring Catalan lion again that we had in
the last game where I was totally
winning and see where he tried to
improve on that
nobody isn't it's Roxy at first I always
forget how that worked
always do that
- yeah I mean it just repeats the same
stuff it's completely bonkers yeah he
had absolutely zilch
in the last game was lost out of the
opening almost
let's see where the great improvement
comes
yeah there is no great improvement place
the same stuff again don't believe it
last game we had Bishop before he for
Luke on the a through P to g6
and I'm not totally okay yeah where's
your improvement
ya know I know you're thinking it's a
bit late let's see what he's coming up
with got a pretty little waiting for his
standards okay this one so just rook c4
oh it says something something better
I shouldn't be bad and we know what
happens if i take too long
he will shuffle this position till no
end so let's be quick about it
it's maybe not the best move but it's
not a bad move
and it's actually a good way of playing
against we place the same stuff all the
time you can play one of those super dry
lines and prepare them to total death
yeah it's just that I really don't like
to invest any time on this stuff and
this on this issue so on I never really
put much time into that this line I once
studied I'm two minutes up on the clock
what is what is wrong with him I um kind
of did he he blue screen maybe something
like that
whereas he disconnected or something no
he isn't
so this lets put pressure on this so
what is he going to do this cannot be
bad having g6 in and he's angling for
Lucas 7 but in the process he has
completely misplaced this rook as on f3
so if I take here rook F 7 doesn't
really help but he cannot really cover
this anyway so I made the apron so why
not just drop back and prevent d7
I'm also fired on the clock
so anything here 94-96 this could be
some trick
in any way they'll take us so night is
six hmm telling that that might happen
how to play this maybe 96 rook c8 would
be good
check Roxy one
check 96 I go rook c8
maybe rook f6 or something attacking my
pawn no way to sitting comes with this
hmm yeah that's a good move I guess it's
a good move
look he's got night b5 okay no I didn't
play that well shouldn't have come to
this Bishop c5 is that any good
don't think so it's difficult though
it's very difficult to get my pawn going
that's not great
oh I totally forgot that he checks
before him hmm I really forgot that he
attacks the pawn wanted to go rook on
the seventh I really played badly
against him I really don't know what
that is he really played that like
nauseous ly bad and I still don't win
amazing I can go on the seventh time
which she doesn't do of course anyway
check drop offered you know what screw
you draw oh yeah this is the thing yeah
he plays every crab on time absolutely
Kevin crept and now he's an ass about it
you know this is why this guy is a
complete [ __ ] you know he thinks I
give him the drone oh yeah he's so
unfair player ever
yeah and now he's annoying with constant
draw office amazing
amazing check you know what one minutes
twenty up and I'm not going to give you
a draw here white for events aren't I'm
not so bad right if you've got one
minute twenty of but just just roles
reversed yeah me being me playing the
usual crap that she plays and just being
quick about it yeah it was bad though I
should have just won the game like that
not quite sure where to improve to six
that must be right it really must be
that also is right and somewhere here
probably some way here yeah I got
irritated by this ninety-six business
the engine just wants to do this and and
and claims a complete win and why is
this not working I have work see one
check okay so I was I was irritated by
this mostly but now I'm not threatening
he's not threatening anything it's just
winning came and if he does that I can
always escape to age six I guess so I
can just push pawns here yeah that's a
very good sir it's a clear win really
yeah okay check so this was a mistake
I didn't I didn't see Rukia coming who
kf6 was also interesting
yeah but is this part of the game I
really played badly and this is a draw I
think I'm active enough to draw this
check check
well okay I really against every any
other play I am I would of course take
the draw but not against him absolutely
nothing absolutely no okay thanks for
watching